régis bonjour alors d'abord il faut
comprendre clie adnane abou walid al
sahraouis de l'état islamique dans le
grand sahara parfois désigné sous le
sigle oui j'ai s'il s'agit d'un cacique
en fait du jihadisme au sel qui a
coopéré étroitement avec moctar ben
moctar l'un des chefs djihadistes qui
était le plus redouté au salk et abou
bakr al baghadi notamment donc ce sont
des coopérations entre ces trois figures
qui ont été éliminés
oui tout à fait et lorsque c'est
intéressant la personnalité de danza oui
de dabou à l'idéal sahraoui c'est que
d'abord c'est un art et comme le dit son
nom c'est un lien de l'ouest du puits
sahara occidental de cette zone vous
savez que l'on contesté comment à bien
sans mouvement indépendantiste qui
s'appelle le front polisario qui date
qui remonte aux années 70 il a fait
partie d'ailleurs de ce front polisario
il a été dans sa jeunesse où il vivait à
l'époque où il vivait dans les camps en
algérie donc en tant que sahraouis
réfugiés sahraouis il a fait partie du
front polisario avant de verser dans la
radicalité un peu dans la même manière
que certains ancien bassiste l'époque de
saddam hussein ont ensuite rejoint dèche
il a ensuite structure et beaucoup de
mouvement vous avez évoqué un motard
belmokhtar évidemment l'algérien avec
qu'il avait il a travaillé main dans la
main il a fondé ce qu'on a appelé le
monde zhao qui a été un des mouvements
les plus durs les plus radicaux pour
essaimer le jihad en afrique et en
particulier au sahel et surtout sa
sahraoui ces dernières années avait
réussi quelque chose d'assez comment
audacieux quelque part c'est à dire
d'utiliser les rivalités locales et tous
les problèmes que contient le sahel par
exemple au niveau 2 de l'ethnie des
peuhls c'est l'épeule vous savez ce sont
des commandes et nomade qui ont été
longtemps menacé par les agriculteurs ja
cette opposition nomades sédentaires en
afrique et lui il a utilisé la
frustration des peuls justement qui se
sont vus comme en privé de leur
territoire pour les radicaliser pour
monter le jihad et monter des opérations
d'opposition justement entre ces ethnies
il a joué fine même s'il avait un
ancrage local très important ce qui lui
a permis d'éviter plaint beaucoup de
fois d'être détecté d'être éliminé par
les forces françaises de marc khanne
plusieurs fois il a failli être tuée il
ya à chaque fois réussi à s'échapper
même à une lors d'un combat il a été
blessé il s'est retrouvé tout seul et il
a réussi à rejoindre les siens
pratiquement à pied donc c'est quelqu'un
qui est très aguerris c'était un comment
un intellectuel
c'était quelqu'un qui avait vraiment une
assise et qui avait réussi à implanter
le lit gs alors je rappelle que le ps
donc c'est l'état islamique dans le
grand sahara qui a été reconnue par
aboubaker al baghdadiya avant sa mort
donc par le khalife de l'état islamique
donc une grande importance pour l'armée
française c'est évidemment un succès
incontestable ça surtout à un moment où
la même armée française où la présence
de l'armée française en afrique et au
sahel en particulier est contestée les
remises en cause notamment par les les
autorités maliennes qui me menacent de
faire notamment un accord avec le groupe
wagner de mercenaires russes écrire et
attention ça c'est un succès régis
souligné par à emmanuel macron pour
autant est-ce que la situation à les
maîtriser dans la région des trois
frontières qui regroupe le mali le niger
et le burkina faso non ça reste le la
zone des trois frontières va est un acte
dans un cloaque été un vivier de
djihadistes assez conséquent le problème
de cette région là il n'ya une zone par
exemple allouer
les français sont répartis entre trois
endroits si vous voulez il ya le gourma
la zone de gao au milieu et la zone de
ménaka halal est et dans cette zone deux
médailles ménaka il est monté en
puissance de ce qu'on a appelé la force
takouba qui kills qui en regroupe un
certain nombre de forces spéciales
européennes
spécialisées dans la formation de
l'armée malienne et dans la lutte contre
les djihadistes mais néanmoins il reste
des zones entières qui ne sont plus
contrôlés par l'armée malienne je pense
à la ville d'in d'elimane par exemple
qui a été attaqué par le mjs en 2019 et
dans lequel n'y a toujours pas de
présence de l'armée donc le problème
c'est ce n'est pas tant de tuer des
chefs djihadistes effectivement il est
important de le faire parce que c'est
eux qui structure le mouvement mais
l'important c'est d'arriver à faire en
sorte que les services publics
reviennent danser dans ces zones et que
une administration puisse prendre la
place de l'armée française qui elle fait
le travail si vous voulez c'est un
travail de contre insurrection et ce
travail de contre insurrection
malheureusement est un parfaitement
faire voire pas du tout et la zone reste
extrêmement instable et donc est une
zone de 2 est un terroir de privilégier
pour les djihadistes qui évidemment
profite de cette instabilité justement
le travail de l'armée française que vous
évoquez il faut quand même rappeler
contexte il ya eu main un retrait de
barkan l'opération française au sahel
finalement cela dit quoi maintenant sur
la stratégie de lutte contre les groupes
terroristes dans le sahel stratégie de
lutte française mais aussi avec les
armées africaines je pense qu au g5
sahel mais écoutez le retrait l'arrêt de
barkan est un signe que emmanuel macron
a voulu donner en particulier aux
putschistes au gouvernement malien qui
skie dirigée par le colonel assimi aux
états que ce il faut que les maliens
prennent en main leur destin la question
et c'est un peu l'âme la même chose que
ce qui s'est produit en afghanistan pour
les américains les américains ont fait
le constat que qu'il reste 50 + 5 en
deux mois ça ne changerait rien à la
situation je dirais que la situation
peut encore évoluer favorablement au
sahel elle n'est pas totalement
désespérée mais il est fort à parier que
si les choses restent en l'état dans
cinq ans la présence française sera
toujours
la même et il risque de ne pas y avoir
d'évolution donc à quai la question est
ce le message qu'a voulu faire passer
emmanuel macron à mon sens en
terminant justement l'opération barkan
et on réduisant les forces c'est que les
forces armées maliennes en particulier
les femmes à doivent reprendre le
terrain c'est un colonel
putschiste qui a la tête un ancien des
responsables des services secrets
maliens qui est à la tête du pays il est
entouré d'autres colonel c'est à eux de
faire en sorte que l'armée malienne
puisse se redéployer et que comme je le
disais tout à l'heure les services
publics et l'apport aux populations
l'aide aux populations que ce faire
parce que la question du mali
aujourd'hui c'est que c'est un état
failli c'est un état dans lesquels il y
à des pans entiers du territoire qui ne
sont pas contrôlés et ce ne sont pas les
quelques 4000 français aidés par la
minus may 1 4000 autres qui vont pouvoir
contrôler tout ce territoire vous avez
souligné l'existence du g5 sahel la
force par cam à la base elle et elle
s'applique ce g5 sahel et ça va de la
mauritanie jusqu'au tchad c'est à peu
près un million de kilomètres carrés il
est évident qu'il faut des relais et il
faut qu'il y ait une solution avec un
pouvoir de transition civile qui puisse
reprendre en main le pays et le discuter
justement à ces groupes djihadistes qui
sont comme des poissons dans l'eau alors
vous soulignez a très justement la
nécessité de réformer les les forces
armées africaines surtout quand on sait
que on parlait de moctar ben moctar l'un
de ses objectifs c'était de former une
grande coalition jihadistes dans tout ça
elle avec ses figures dont adnane abou
walid al sahraouis qui est dédié a été
désormais qui est éliminé quel avenir
justement pour cette ambition de former
une grande coalition djihadistes au
sahel est ce que ça c'est une encore une
vraie menace malgré l'élimination de ces
figures du djihadisme alors c'est vrai
que mokhtar mokhtar belmokhtar est
probablement mort qu on n'est pas la
preuve absolue de deux ans ne voit là de
sa de son décès sahraoui éliminé
également un certain nombre de grosses
figures du djihad historiques y compris
du djihad monde en remontant à l'époque
du gia en algérie ont été éliminés
néanmoins il reste que l'idée de la
grande coalition a quand même du plomb
et du plomb dans l aile il y à une
opposition assez marquée entre le js
donc les thaïs aiment dans le grand
sahara et chimie qui lui est rattaché à
al qaïda et qu'ils se trouvent et qui
opèrent plus dans le nord du mali donc
il ya une opposition entre ces deux
groupes ils ont parfois trouvé des
trouver des terrains d'entente mais ils
se sont aussi affrontés et il reste des
groupes rivaux donc il n'ya pas de
véritable coalition de groupes
djihadistes et de grande coalition de
groupes djihadistes au sahel en ce
moment il y a néanmoins des gros
parfaitement efficace que ce soit aqmi
d'un côté et le sgs2 l'autre merci à
beaucoup avoue régis le sommier grand
reporter à alerter france